bonjour bienvenue dans ce ca au caddie
du mercredi 27 mars avec ce matin pour
inviter donc malik mal ça bonjour
bonjour
car oui merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes membre fondateur du
grable groupement régional des
agriculteurs bio de la martinique et
vous êtes actuellement membre du bureau
de de ce grave alors rappelez nous ce
qu'est ce grave qui est maintenant bien
inscrit dans le paysage agricole de la
martinique il ya quelques années vous
étiez des avant gardistes maintenant bon
le bio tout le monde s'y intéresse tout
le monde ne peut peut-être pas encore se
le payer parce que parfois c'est un peu
cher mais voilà donc vous êtes bien rodé
maintenant c'est ça c'est ça on est bien
et three damgan dans le paysage donc des
groupements martinique est donc le grab
comme vous l'avez dit c'est le
groupement régional d'agriculteurs bio
un en martinique dans son rôle essentiel
donc c'est justement de fédérer dans
tous les acteurs de l'agriculture
biologique en martinique pour qui il
s'agit donc essentiellement des
producteurs un producteur bio et
transformateurs qui sont rien de façon à
avoir une visibilité un haut niveau dans
kde du pays
manik pas ça vous dit que donc votre le
rôle de ce groupement est son nom
indique c'est de fédérer mais est ce que
le grab regroupe réuni fédère tous les
producteurs bio de lille alors pour
l'instant malheureusement non 1
malheureusement non mais nous sommes
quand même plus de la moitié sachant que
bon il ya une soixantaine de producteurs
aujourd'hui inscrit donc à l' agence bio
1 donc parmi ces 60 ne sont plus d'une
trentaine qui aujourd'hui adhérent aux
graves qui sont adhérents au grab donc
maintenant c'est une question de
conviction un mais et puis il fonction
de conviction de ses agriculteurs pour
vous rejoindre ou pour vous graver de
les convaincre de vous rejoindre
alors c'est qu'on ne vienne pas pourquoi
il
c'est vrai qu'ils ne sont pas tous ne
sont pas encore décidés à venir il ils
attendent peut-être qu'on fasse donc des
actions beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
intéressante donc à leur niveau mais
nous nous nous attachons donc à mener
donc à essayer de les convaincre
parce que si notre rôle à nous vouloir
absolument fédérer parce qu'aujourd'hui
pour être visible il faut être au pays
alors on vous invitez parce que il y a
quelques jours vous avez eu l'occasion
de rencontrer un des candidats têtes de
liste aux élections aux prochaines
élections européennes il s'agit d'un
écologiste yannick jadot qui qui était
donc en tournée aux antilles en guyane
il est passé par par la martinique tête
de liste d'europe écologie les verts
vous avez eu l'occasion d'échanger avec
lui
qu'est ce que vous lui avez dit qu'est
ce que vous avez dit des difficultés et
des aspirations des doléances de la part
des agriculteurs bio en tout cas de ceux
qui sont aux graves absolument fascicolo
gist c'est ça c'est vrai qu'on a pu donc
le rencontrer lors d'une visite donc
d'une ferme sur le saint joseph où il
tenait absolument à rencontrer dans
quelques producteurs en bio donc dont
des producteurs du groupement et et sa
voix donc nos difficultés comment nos
portions et c'est ce que nous avons en
tout cas relaté pas mal de difficultés
un con qu'on retrouve un puisque vous
savez que là quand vous êtes aujourd'hui
même si c'est une agriculture qui est
très demandé
aujourd'hui mais il faut qu'on fasse
attention faut qu'on fasse attention
notamment à à ceux mêmes qui ont souvent
décrié l'agriculture biologique et qui
par opportunisme uns veulent rentrer
donc on veut absolument créer des jalons
pour nous protéger d'ailleurs le slogan
on n'entre pas en agriculture bio et
notamment dans ce groupement régional
comme dans un moulin quoi faut quand
même
remplir un certain nombre de d'abord de
charge parce que bon le label bio c'est
pas ça se donne pas accès
absolument c'est vrai que le label bio
comme vous le dites donc si c'est très
réglementé
mais en plus de ça je crois que avec
tous les scandales qu'on n'entend pas ce
que parfois cela même veulent
discréditer
je veux vous rappeler par exemple le
problème l'an dernier qui a eu autour de
la banane où il parlait au salon de
l'agriculture un banane françaises
guadeloupe et martinique mieux que bio
c'est possible donc ça ça cccc du
scandale ça c'est mépriser effectivement
un travail que nous nous faisons
régulièrement pour nourrir sainement nos
peuples
donc on veut retrouver du crédit et par
conséquent au sein de ce groupement donc
à plus donc d'être certifié nous
effectivement nous nous tenons à ce qui
est donc ce qu'on appelle il faut il
faut effectivement que ces six personnes
rentrent dans la logique de
l'agriculture biologique
c'est un sas et c'est très important
pour nous parce que faire du du bio
industrielle je crois que c'est
complètement sortir de l'esprit même du
bio et si rentrer dans les mêmes travers
comptes dénonce tous les jours donc de
l'agriculture conventionnelle
alors qu'est ce que vous attendez de la
part de de l'union européenne de d'élus
au parlement européen qu'est ce que
c'est
quel serait votre demande prioritaire
quoi vis-à-vis alors je dis ça mais des
pouvoirs publics d'une manière générale
du gouvernement mais aussi de des
instances européennes
absolument donc c'est vrai quoi bon on
se fait pas trop d'illusions non plus
mais c'est vrai qu'on sait qu'une
élection européenne à ce niveau pour sur
le plan agricole reste important
importante parce que on sait que tout se
joue à bruxelles l'avenir de
l'agriculture malheureusement
martiniquais s'est beaucoup là et donc
il faut absolument qu'on ait de vrais
rôles et à ce niveau dont beaucoup ont
compris ça vous compris ça c'est pour ça
que d'ailleurs ils sont aussi bien et
donc pour nous c'est pour autant d'avoir
des relais on
déjà au niveau de la fnam par exemple la
fédération nationale de l'agriculture
biologique
mais il en faut également donc d'élus
convaincu donc de notre cause dont
d'ailleurs les élus écologistes sont
très sensibles donc à cette code d'accès
si c'est un peu pour ça donc on a eu
cette approche mais j'ai envie de dire
surtout aux élus de martinique de
prendre conscience que l'agriculture
biologique
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas que
l'agriculture en soit si c'est une
question de santé publique dont sans
parler de purement d'agriculture il
s'agit de la santé donc du peuple
martiniquais donc dans cette affaire et
donc il faut pas faire de scission entre
les deux si quand on parle donc de santé
dans ce pays il faut parler
d'alimentation et agriculture une âme
une alimentation saine pour une
meilleure santé possible
absolument et visuellement et si c'est
beaucoup ça que notre alimentation saine
en indiquant bien je vous interromps
parce que évidemment dix minutes ça
passe très vite
il nous reste à peine deux minutes pour
terminer je reviens sur donc le
fonctionnement du grab vous l'avez dit
bon un peu plus de 50 % des agriculteurs
biologiques de lille se retrouve au sein
de ce groupement
mais est-ce que ce groupement votre état
d'esprit c'est vraiment la mutualisation
les échanges solidaires entre vous est
ce que c'est un groupement de ce point
de vue là parce que moi certains m'ont
dit quand ils ont entendu que vous
alliez être notre invité ils ont demandé
par exemple pourquoi le jardin de la
santé ne commercialise pas les produits
des collègues
pourquoi alors aussi bien placé donc du
jardin de la santé mais si que figurez
vous qu'au sein du groupement patronal
on a crié un résout donc de boutiques
affirme de façon à ce que la production
biologique soit au plus près de la
population donc du nord au sud de la
martinique
un exemple donc nous retrouvons des
points relais à notre production et donc
c'est essentiellement dû bricoler
la vôtre avoue non et donc ma production
bien sûr mais aussi ses mais également
parce que je ne produis pas tous dans
pour avoir une clip une plus belle
diversité donc de produire à proposer
donc aux consommateurs oui plus que tout
non il faut pas je crois pas qu'il
faille rentrer donc dans ces choses à
nous nous voulons fédérer miss you des
des causes clé donc il faut que ceux qui
veulent rentrer donc dans ce mouvement
soit d'abord certifier ça c'est une
chose de l'accord son prix voilà et le
recrutement mutualisé ça marche c'est en
projet deux ans après on me dit non ça
n'aboutit pas lorsqu'elle question de
révéler son nom mais le recrutement
mutualisé bon on y travaille c'est vrai
que bon il faut puisque ce que nous
cherchons c'est d'avoir donc des gens
formés aussi à l'agriculture biologique
donc ça prend un peu de temps
malheureusement je peux comprendre donc
la tante de certains voiles à certains
mais ça arrive et ça avance donc le bio
a de beaux jours devant lui en
martinique que le bio a de très beaux
jours nous en vendée car en vous nous
voulons encourager donc la jeunesse
martiniquaise à s'installer mais nous
savons très vite nous savons qu'il ya
des difficultés notamment bon niveau
donc de référentiels mais nous nous
attachons à travailler sérieusement
dessus depuis quelques années et nous
savons donc façon que l'agriculture
biologique c'est l'avenir de la menti
merci malik mal ça d'avoir répondu à nos
questions certains n'étaient pas qu'on
plaisante mais c'est la loi du genre
donc voila merci d'avoir accepté très
bien merci aux membres donc du grave le
groupement régional des arts culture bio
de la martinique bonne journée à vous
tous à bercy
[Musique]